holly what would you like to confess
today i have a guy that likes to come
and pick up my laundry the dirtier the
better to be honest so he takes my
smelly socks and panties takes them away
washes them
probably sniffs them a lot and does
whatever he does and then brings them
back so that's really convenient for me
actually because it means i just get rid
of some of my laundry
[Music]
my confession is i deactivated all of my
ex's netflix accounts to get back at
them
and did they ever find out
they found out that it was deactivated
but they did not find out it was me
what did he do to you to deserve deserve
that revenge most of them cheated
and all just like treating me really
badly
so i think it's fair enough sounds like
you've had a lot of tricky men in your
life esther my confession is i've faked
every single orgasm that a man has never
given me yet not one single boyfriend
has ever guessed
[Music]
i would like to confess that my
great-granddad actually killed my
great-grandma when my name was 11
and then i found out that he was
actually a serial killer what does it
take to become a serial killer
you have to kill three or more people
and is this is this something that you
tell people is this or is this something
you've kept a secret
i had to keep it a secret when i was
younger because
my mum didn't know anything about it she
didn't know that he was classified as a
serial killer she
didn't know that he killed more than my
great-grandma yeah i i wasn't allowed to
talk about it when i was 14 15 but then
as i looked into it more i realized it
was already
quite
public just not in the
21st century
how does it feel confessing it now
getting up saying this out loud getting
off your chest
if it feels
i feel
bad almost
because um
it's not a good thing
but i also can acknowledge that
it's interesting at the same time
what would you like to confess today my
confession is my parents have no idea
that i'm dropping out of university in
second year to pursue acting and to do
youtube full-time
why haven't you told them
um
because they want me to go to university
and get a degree they want me to have a
back-up plan which is fair enough but it
just isn't for me what do you think they
want you to do
um
be a doctor or something
something generic
i would like to confess that i piss
myself at my mate's house
all right what happened so basically uh
i went on a night out as you do got very
drunk and my mates were like look you
can't go home you're staying at mine and
i was like all right cool well i didn't
say that i was more like
oh okay cool anyway so i ended up
sitting at my friend's house and he put
me in a really nice sleeping bag tucked
me away i fell asleep i woke up really
hungover and also extremely wet i
basically did the biggest piss of my
life in the sleeping bag and i had no
idea what to do so i was like right i've
got two options here either confess it
well i don't so i rolled that sleeping
bag up i put it in the airing car but
shut the door
and i went home
i was catfished by a member of staff
that i worked with
quite closely and that set up this whole
fake persona there was actually pillow
talk and everything involved only for my
horror to find out two weeks later this
was an actual person that uh i i was
actually working with and they set it up
in such a way that uh
they would put up updated profiles
pictures it was done on a whole
day-to-day basis
and it left me just feeling quite sick
to the pit of my stomach still to this
day i shudder
i did actually confront them and they
then took down all their instagram page
their facebook page and they then all
these other uh guys came out of the
woodwork saying listen that's so surreal
because i see that you posted up and
i've had exactly the same experience
still to this day it left such a bad
taste in my mouth it's like made me feel
absolutely sick
and it's still ongoing because i still
have fake profiles on instagram and it's
but now i can spot them really well i'm
really good i'm like a detective you can
kind of look and go
something doesn't look right there and
yes it's still kind of happening so i'm
a sex worker and i have some sexual
requests that you wouldn't believe
what is the like the weirdest sort of
stuff that you get asked some shocking
examples are i do have a client that's
almost 90 years old
and he likes to be caned
another one is i have a guy that likes
to come and pick up my laundry the
dirtier the better to be honest so he
takes my smelly socks and panties takes
them away washes them
probably sniffs them a lot and does
whatever he does and then brings them
back so that's really convenient for me
actually because it means i just get rid
of some of my laundry
there is some things that i don't do
that are just a little bit too over the
line for me
such as um scats
do i need to explain what that is yes
so scat is like
well some people call it hard sports
it's basically poo
say no more pigeons next to you
what would you like to confess today uh
i like to confess that i nearly turned
gay when i was 13. i think every guy has
to go past that like that phase of like
confusion and all that i'm 22 now and
like i'm straight as a ruler when i was
13 if even if i turn gay i'll probably
be
all right because every gender is
beautiful you know what would you say to
your 13 year old self i'll say there's
nothing wrong with being anything you
can be anything in this world just just
be happy i guess
i was once a house party i didn't know
the host but i was invited by my mate
and i needed to do a poo so i went in
the toilet and i did my business and i
panicked i didn't want to get out of the
toilet to a queue of people smelling my
own poo so i jumped out of the window
and walked back into the house
and then did you walk back into the
house and then act shocked that someone
had done a smelly poo no i just
completely ignored it none of my
business i have no idea what happened
sometimes when my friends come back from
night sight and they're hungover they
can't remember what they've done
i'll make something up and tell them
that they've done it while they're drunk
so you're single-handedly fueling your
friend's beer fear yeah i really was
um sometimes i'll make up stories that
they've kissed old men
you know what
just some things to have a little bit of
fun have a little giggle to yourself and
do they know that you're doing this no
i don't think anyone will trust me after
an idol again
i confess that in a zoo meeting i had
sex with the camera and the microphone
turned off all right tell me more my now
ex was over and i was logged in to a
team's conference call and basically um
i logged on i did my thing
and then turned off the camera turned
off the mic and then just had really
loud sex while the
the call was going on in the background
did it add an extra a level for you with
the uh the fact that the meeting was
still going on yeah it was kind of it
was just kind of it was kind of risky
kind of fun so it was like that was part
of the appeal i guess is there something
you'd do again
oh well we did we did do it again
[Music]
what would you like to confess today
i'd like to confess today that i have
never had been on a date
still a virgin at 23 years old now never
like done anything more than just
have a conversation to be honest how do
you feel about that
um i feel i feel great to be honest i
mean i don't really need to date to have
a good life i'm still young
life is not short as well we still got
we've still got a future ahead so i
guess yeah i just like to take things
slow fair enough let them come to you
rixton yes
i've got a form of ocd that means that i
have intrusive and damaging thoughts
about my partner's previous past and
have spent a lot of the last couple of
years thinking about what she did before
me what kind of things do you do you end
up focusing on and thinking about so
obviously we met on a dating app so it
first started with who else she met on
that dating app